for the past two years we've answered a
lot of your burning questions but there
are many we've yet to cover so we
decided to embark on a new project that
we're excited to finally share with you
introducing the ASAP science book
answers to the world's weirdest
questions most persistent rumors and
unexplained phenomena okay okay enough
reverb not only can you now own a
physical version of some of your
favorite video episodes which we've
redrawn and updated but we wrote a whole
bunch of new chapters answering
questions that have never been answered
here on ASAP science like does shaving
make your hair grow thicker will tell
you can sneezing pop your eyeballs out
you'll see or could you spontaneously
combust it's perfect for anyone who
wants to find out the science behind it
all the book is officially available for
pre-orders now you can go to ASAP
science comm slash book to find out
where to get it we'd be so appreciative
if you checked it out and helped spread
the word it's been a huge pet project
first that we're really proud of and
hopefully a chance to feed your brains
hunger for some more sweet science
seriously your continued support through
these couple years has meant the world
to us and we honestly can't thank you
enough with your help we've been able to
share our love of science with the world
and that's pretty dang cool so head over
to ASAP science comm to get your
pre-order and satiate those burning
questions